hi I'm just I Olson from northfield
minnesota I'm fairly new to
screenwriting last year I wrote my first
script and then over the summer I
co-directed the film with a buddy of
mine so after we completely finished
that film I switched gears and I started
writing a different story in book format
but what I found after about four months
of you know writing and editing that is
that I'm not I'm not as good with words
um you know I I see the story in
pictures I'm a very visual guy um and so
putting it in the word I just I couldn't
I couldn't write it and get the same
emotion into it and so I'm switching
back now to writing a script again this
will be my second script it's titled
troubled water um I've only been working
on it for several months now so it still
has a long ways to go it's a story about
the trap of hate it's a battle it it's
about the way past mistakes and the
consequences are kind of in avoidable
I'm very excited about the story that's
what convinced me that I will finish it
on the reason I'm writing it is just
because I can't not right you know it's
it's kind of something I can't stop
thinking about it end I really like to
see it as a movie a finished movie and
so I'm going to make it for myself
essentially but I'm really hoping that
you'll be there be people that
appreciate it on and they enjoy it as
much as I would the reason and
persevering with this project and I
haven't quit it's just because I I
really believe that any project no
matter what you know how bad the final
result ends up maybe being arm is really
just a learning experience so I'm hoping
that even if you know even if the
project doesn't end up going all the way
it doesn't end up they made the movie at
least I'll have another script under my
belt and you know you learn from every
step of the way my mentality is keep
writing and eventually you'll find gold
you know um but you I mean you'll never
know if it's good or not until you've
actually finished and shown to somebody
and you know you have finished result to
be able to look at my goals with the
script number one I just I want to
finish it and I want to be able to see
it turn into a movie that would be
incredible I'd be completely content
with that um and a step up from
I'd really love to just see some really
great actors I'd love to you know get a
good team of people working on it um you
know some great editors things like that
I'd really love to see a quality to it
for a final goal i would say i'd really
like to get into a film festival on our
first film I'll admit was really it was
subpar it wasn't film festival worthy
and so with this one I I think since we
learned so much from the first project
that this one we're going to see a huge
improvement and hopefully it will be
something I can sign up to a film
festival with the clear conscience two
things that screen writings taught me
one is that making a movie is a team
sport you know you've got so many people
that have to get involved you've got the
director you've got the cameraman the
sound technicians you've got art
department you got acted you know
there's just no end to the list of the
jobs that can go into making a really
successful movie you know the more
people you have helping out the more
quality you can get out of it I believe
I'm always amazed but you know you go to
a theater you watch the film and at the
end of it you just see this like
never-ending list of names like hundreds
of names and the thing is every single
one of them was completely necessary to
make the film you just watch so that I
mean I think it's pretty hard to
organize all those people and get that
together that's probably the hardest
thing to get all those people working
together you really need a good good
script to begin with you don't have a
good script you you've already lost you
know because you have to catch the
attention of these actors you have to
get people that are just as excited
about making this film as you are
without that enthusiasm you're not going
to be able to make a great movie the
second lesson is that film is art
essentially it's art in its purest form
I i love art I I paint I draw I write a
play guitar I think that's what really
attracts me that film as a medium
because it's just got all this art it's
got summat ography composition music got
characters in fashion design oh it's
poetry so fellas when all these art
forms come together and you know they
make this melody it's easy to get caught
up in the you know the action the plot
twists the mind
blowing visual effects and you know that
side of film but essentially the art
side you know the core of film if you
don't have that you lose the beauty of
it I'm writing all the time for my my
scripts I mean not not physically
putting on the paper but I'm always
thinking about it you know like the most
writing i get done is when i'm in a car
right I'll be sitting there looking at
the window and figuring out how I'm
going to get a character to point a to
point b how I'm going to transform you
know character are excited and I think I
get the most done in that kind of
situation but as far as actually giving
you end up paper I really have to
schedule that because if I don't
schedule it I i procrastinate you know I
lose interest in certain scenes I I I
just worked with this slow so that's
something that should be helping me as a
screenwriter is the scheduled time for
myself so that I do not let myself
procrastinate as far as my goals as a
screenwriter I just want to keep going
with it I it I'm starting film school
next year so I just want to learn more
about the process of you know film
editing camera work there's just so much
more for me to learn I guess my biggest
dream is screenwriting and filmmaking
doses I would just love to get my own
studio I think that would just be really
awesome so with the last film that we
made um we did not have was time we were
always rushed we were we sometimes had
scenes where we literally had like five
minutes to film them I remember there
was one where we had to do this quick
scene in a car you know just a little
car ride and my buddy was like I gotta
go to work right now here you know the
lead actor and we're like I you know you
said you'd be here can we can we quit
film it and so like we filmed it in the
car on the way to work so I mean we we
really didn't have time it was a pretty
rushed process but I'm overall really
proud of how I first film turned out
because I mean the amazing part is that
we finished it we got a full 50 minute
film which is pretty incredible for a
three month process um then we put it
all together really fast I think time
is where the quality can come in you
know and so the next project i work on I
really want to be able to put more time
into it so thanks for watching I really
hope you enjoyed it and I can't wait to
get back from you guys i really enjoy
your channel and i think this is awesome
when you guys are doing so once again
thanks for watching take care